يريد نتنياهو تأجيل الصفقة قدر الإمكان
لماذا ممكن لماذا لأن كل العلامات حتى الآن
الأشهر الأربعة الأخيرة تظهر أنه ليس كذلك
يريد أن تنتهي هذه الحرب، لذلك لا يناقش
وبغض النظر عن كيفية انتهاء الأمر، فإنه يحبط الصفقات
لهذا السبب لم يضع صفقتنا على الطاولة
هذه ليست صفقة مبادرتنا
زوت هو أيضا عشرة أن صفقة المخدرات هي مبادرة
كل هذه الأشياء تؤدي إلى نتيجة واحدة
إنه خائف جدًا بسبب وضعه السياسي الذي تخوضه الحرب
أنهي مشاهدة هذه القيء وهي تتم بشكل أفضل على الإطلاق
لا أحد يعرف شيئا عنهم
لقد تحدثنا معك، هذا جيد، لقد أخبرتني بذلك
من الجميل أن نتحدث عن السبعينيات، ولكن بقدر ما يعرف الناس
ناهيك عن أن هناك صفقة على الإطلاق وأن هناك تفاصيل عنها بهذه الطريقة
يتا ونتنياهو يعرفان ذلك ولذلك فهو ح مايكل
شيمش مراسلنا السياسي الذي تنشره عن التورط
نتنياهو في محاولات لتأجيل تفتيش المدقق
صحيح جداً وغير عادي أن نتنياهو يحاول فعلاً
أوقف هذا الاختبار قبل أن يبدأ
ويرسل رئيس الوزراء يوسي فوكس
للقاء مع رئيس الدولة نتنياهو إنجلمان في لقاء
وهذا ما يطلب سكرتير الحكومة من المدقق رفضه
الفحص المتعلق بالحرب وأسباب هذا الطلب
إنه ضرر محتمل للمجهود الحربي كما يقول
يوسي فوكس لنتنياهو إنجلمان يطلب منه التأجيل
التفتيش أيضا فيما يتعلق بمكتب رئيس الوزراء أيضا
فيما يتعلق بالجهات الأمنية الأخرى في المركز الرئيسي
وردت الحكومة على هذه الأمور التي ذكرها
وطلبت الحكومة من مدقق الحسابات النظر في البث المباشر وقت التحرير
الانتقاد خلال الحرب لأنه يمكن أن يضر
في المجهود الحربي بطريقة أو بأخرى، أيضا المكتب الرئيسي
كما لم تنجح الحكومة في أي من الهيئات الخاضعة للرقابة
في الوقت الحالي، لا يبدو متحمسًا لمثل هذا الاختبار بعد ذلك
أنك طرحت نية مدقق حسابات الدولة لفحصها
سلوك الجيش في الحرب وأمام الناقد
إنجلمان يجيب على مستوى الجميع ويبلغني لا أقصد
انتظروا نير دوري معكم المزيد من التفاصيل في التحقيق
هذا سوف يراه داني هذا المساء والذي يطلب مراقب الدولة
يرسل رسالة جوابية عن رئيس الأركان على ظاهر الأمور
وهو ما ذكرته هنا بالمناسبة، ورئيس الأركان يصر عليه
من وسائل الإعلام ويكتب له هكذا كل العوامل
ويخضع كبار المسؤولين والهيئات الحكومية للتدقيق
لكن لا توجد نية لإزعاج الجيش في المجهود الحربي
يعني هيكون فيه اختبار مش عارف أقولك إزاي
بالضبط كيف ومتى، ولكن كما ترى هناك بالفعل بعض
التراجع عن هذا على الأقل ولكن داني
ومؤخرا، أرسل مراقب الدولة أيضا رسالة
إلى مكتب رئيس الوزراء وهناك يتحدث عن ذلك أو
ويحذرهم من أنهم أيضًا سيخضعون للتدقيق ليس فقط
هم أيضًا النص ويطلب منهم حفظ الكل
الوثائق والوثائق ذات الصلة وهكذا يكتب
مراقب الدولة أتذكر رئيس المكتب الرئيسي
وينبغي للحكومة والسكرتير العسكري كل قرار
ويجب أيضًا استلام جميع الوثائق الخاصة بجميع الاجتماعات كتابيًا
التصرفات والقرارات خلال الحرب وخلال تلك الفترة
والتي تم تقديمها حتى يمكن التحقق منها عليك
احتفظ بجميع المستندات التي تم إرسال هذه الرسالة بها بالمناسبة
بعد أن سمع تقارير إعلامية تفيد بأن البعض
من المحتمل أن يتم اتخاذ القرارات شفهيًا وليس كذلك
كل شيء معتمد لذا فهو يطلب هذا الشيء أيضًا
نحن لا نحصل على الحقائق بشكل صحيح في بعض الأحيان، كلنا نفعل ذلك
لقد أبهرتنا الصور التي التقطت من دير البلح والتي وثقت المظاهرة
ناهيك عن أغنيت، الذي يُزعم أنه خرج بشجاعة ضد هامس
والجيل الحريص على إنهاء الحرب والذي شارك في نشرها
وقد روى هذه القصة المتحدث باسم الجيش الإسرائيلي باللغة العربية، أفيحاي أدرعي
كتب على شبكة قادة داش هامز في بارشو تزينر
اسمع هذا يا كاتب شعبك وأولادك وزوجاتك
ويطالبون بإعادة الإسرائيليين المختطفين
إلى منازلهم حتى تتوقف الحرب فأسرعنا
لتبني القصة في هذا الإطار أيضًا هنا الليلة الماضية
وفي كل استوديو آخر هناك مشاهد لم نر سكانها بعد
فلسطينيون يتظاهرون ضد حماس
وفي الفيديو يمكنك رؤية السكان
يلوح الشريط بلافتات تقول نعم للاعتراف
المختطفون نرى النساء والأطفال هناك
وآخرون يتظاهرون قرب أحد مشافي دير العلا
بليتش ضد حماس المطالبة بوقف الحرب
ومع المطالبة بإطلاق سراح الرهائن الإسرائيليين فماذا
المشكلة هي أننا لم نؤكد بما فيه الكفاية على أن هناك احتمالا
أن هذه المظاهرة هي ضدنا مطلقاً أو على الأقل أيضاً
إن إسرائيل مدعوة إلى وقف المعركة ضدنا
أنت تعتقد حقًا أنه يمكن الترويج للصفقة والاستمرار فيها
علينا أن نواصل القتال ونكمله
التحكم وأود أن تصفية حيث أستطيع
ويحتل مكانًا منفصلاً معنا في ما يشبه المعسكر
جميع أفراد الأسرة النووية من الموظفين
يمكن أن يكون لحم الخنزير دربا، ويمكن أن يكون أيضًا
10 للناس ولكن عليك أن توافق على ما تفعله بالفعل
أن تقول التفكير ليست لحظة عادية في النهاية
إنه شيء يهتمون به ويهمهم أيضًا إذا كنت كذلك
حقا عقد الزوجة والأطفال والابنة وDS بعد ذلك
نعم أنت هنا
يصف الحركات الإبداعية حقًا وليست كذلك
كانت الرتب العسكرية والسياسية روتينية في يوم من الأيام
ربما كان لديهم المزيد من الفسحة وفعلوا ذلك
مثل هذه الأشياء نحن مع هذه المسألة الآن
وتعتزم وزارة الدفاع المضي قدما في تجنيدهم في الجيش
يبلغ عدد أفرادها 1400 عضو، معظمهم من المتدربين الذين لديهم سنوات من الخدمة
والاستعدادات التي ستضطر فعلاً إلى التوقف بسبب القرار
هذه هي الدراسات التي فسرها لنا يائير إيتنغر
أردت أن أشرح لماذا صحيح أن ميشال لديها حرب
الاحتياجات العملياتية ومن الطبيعي أن يحتاج الجيش إلى المزيد
شؤون الموظفين وزارة الدفاع تبلغ الرئيس هذا الأسبوع
المدارس الإعدادية أنه سيضطر إلى مقاطعة العام الدراسي
من هؤلاء الطلاب من 1400 بطليموس
الانواع